el VIH no fue el final sino el comienzo
de una nueva vida aún recuerda cuando
estuvo postrado en una cama de hospital
hoy tiene la energía para andar
repartiendo antirretrovirales a
pacientes que no los tienen de manera
oportuna por inexistencia o retraso en
el suministro en centros de salud lo que
tratamos de hacer es
recoger medicamentos que nos donan No
desde donde sea en cualquier punto de la
Ciudad de México y de otros estados nos
mandan medicamento para nosotros ese
medicamento repartido entre las personas
que nos piden ayuda pues que no tienen
medicamento de acuerdo con la
información del proyecto cero desabasto
entre 2019 y 2022 México reportó 453
denuncias por falta de antirretrovirales
para el doctor hesser Lezama infectólogo
de la clínica Condesa la situación que
atraviesa esta patología en México es
complicada en términos globales en
México ha habido un retroceso del 20 al
30% en las metas de la honoscida para el
2035 actualmente vemos que el 50% de los
pacientes que recientemente son
diagnosticados acuden en etapas
avanzadas de la enfermedad otro problema
es la caída en las pruebas de VIH según
cifras oficiales en 2022 aún no se
recupera el nivel de testeo previo a la
pandemia de covid ante ello Alain y su
grupo vive libre organizan jornadas de
detección y procuran Dar seguimiento
hacer pruebas no es un esfuerzo
para nosotros no es un esfuerzo es
nuestro trabajo diario el esfuerzo es
que tengamos la oportunidad de que la
persona que salió reactiva a cualquier
its
se vincule a los servicios de salud y
obtenga tratamientos el virus de
inmunodeficiencia humana lleva 40 años
en el mundo y ha habido avances en su
control y combate sin embargo en México
los pacientes atribuyen a la homofobia
el que las políticas públicas no les
garanticen calidad de vida